Rachael Dempsey (she/her): awesome well let's get started here and we can let people come in from the waiting room as they join as well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But hi everybody Thank you so much for joining us today welcome to the RStudio enterprise Community meetup, our energy meetup today,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): i'm Rachael calling in from Boston actually in the city at our office today in the seaport if you just joined now feel free to introduce yourself in the chat window and say hello, maybe where you're calling in from,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I like to just let people know at the beginning, if you want to turn on live transcription for the meetup you can do so in the zoom bar below if you just press more,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And, but to go through a brief agenda will have some short introductions of the meetup and welcome everyone here our introduction to functional data analysis with Santiago Rodriguez and then lots of time for questions and open discussion at the end as well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So just a reminder this meetup will be recorded to so it will be shared, to the RStudio YouTube i'll put it on the meetup discussion and on linkedin,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So, to ask questions if you don't want to be part of the recording you can always use the slider link that i'll share in just a moment in the chat,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): You can put your name in there, too, if if you want, and I can call on you to ask the question live or you could ask anonymously,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But for anybody joining, for the first time, welcome this is a friendly and open beta meetup environment for teams to share the work they're doing within their organizations teach lessons learn network with each other, really just allow us all to learn from each other,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So thank you all so much for making this a welcoming community to really want this to be a space where everybody can participate, we can hear from everyone,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Regardless of your level of experience or the industry that you work in So if you ever have suggestions or general feedback, please let me know to i'll share a few other links in the chat as well, where you can do so,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But with that Thank you all again for joining us I would love to turn it over to our speaker Santiago Rodriguez Santiago,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): and I are friends from linkedin that's actually how we first met Santiago is a data scientist in the marketing department at consumers energy a Michigan based public utility,
Santiago: Hi Rachael everybody,
Santiago: And that's exactly right I reached out to Rachel one day because she had a really interesting post on some functions in our that I hadn't heard of them before I thought they were great so I just didn't take a call post and,
Santiago: ended up here you got inspirational for somebody if you have something you want to share reach out there's a community,
Santiago: Okay, so let's get started,
Santiago: our agenda today is going to cover some introductions i'm going to introduce myself the topic a little bit about consumers energy because i'm using some of their data, so I want to give a shout out,
Santiago: definition as to what functional data analysis is,
Santiago: And then the meat of the presentation is really examples and implications of the presence of a functional the analysis, this method of analysis and then we'll wrap up with some resources in case anybody's interested in how I got started,
Santiago: Alright, allow me to introduce myself a little bit further, I was born in Ecuador, South America and so somebody in the chat was from Columbia Hello neighbor,
Santiago: I grew up in South Florida and i've lived in Dallas Texas for seven years or so, I have a bachelor's from Florida State University and a master's in statistics from Texas a&m I currently work as a data scientist and marketing,
Santiago: i've had the pleasure of working across different industries, primarily because i'm a learner and,
Santiago: I love learning new things and different industries different functions and then, when i'm at work i'm currently reading,
Santiago: Usually stats books and if it's not as books it's fiction nonfiction,
Santiago: I like to travel, this year, my wife and I have dedicated time to traveling and I love the fish I grew up in South Florida there's a body of water and run every corner,
Santiago: on me to introduce consumers energy you're sort of their the sponsor of the data this presentation and say public utility found in Michigan being served the majority of michigan's residents and have a generation capacity in about six gigawatts,
Santiago: And then about today,
Santiago: My talk will be primarily descriptive non technical we won't get into math or code really it's all about what is functional data analysis and how can you use it, what are applications and my goal today is to introduce this relatively young branches statistics,
Santiago: And then show you that it has value that it can add value that it's worth your time to explore and maybe learn as well,
Santiago: And I got started with this other share that really quickly i'm by no means an expert on functional data analysis i've been playing around with this stuff for a few months, probably close to a year and,
Santiago: In the utility space meter reads our primary data source for a lot of things and,
Santiago: The time series nature of,
Santiago: A meter reads allow you to do a couple different interesting things if you're a time series person you become positions and other more traditional stuff I found that,
Santiago: functional analysis with meter reads was such a perfect combination and i'll show you some examples in a bit,
Santiago: As far as logistics i've added little break points into the presentation currently to give me a break a glass of water, I need, and if you have any questions you can ask a question,
Santiago: In that section that way you don't forget or I don't forget what the heck I was talking about, maybe it's a little bit more relevant in that point in time,
Santiago: All right, first up this is an academic section sort of it's a definition, what can we do with national day announces it's the only math formula formula you'll see today,
Santiago: And it's useful upfront before we get into applications to define what this is what functionally announces in FDA is,
Santiago: that's the acronym FDA announces it's an analysis of information on curves and functions for our purposes today we're going to highlight curves, but if you work in let's say the spatial data, you can use functions,
Santiago: As well functional functional data analysis is essentially a non parametric flexible regression technique that is used to approximate occur in what we say,
Santiago: Okay, here we go it's used to approximate a curve or function, be a linear combination of bases functions, it looks like a regression formula, you have coefficients and,
Santiago: Points right data in this case there's a slight tweak where what we're trying to do is using these red dots in this case, these are meetings are bigger using the data we're going to fit a curves,
Santiago: Right we're going to approximate occurs,
Santiago: Using ACS functions and that's that fee function in the formula it's a non parametric function and has the form of the bottom right graph it looks like wines,
Santiago: And that's that's essentially it I don't want to get too into the weeds here you have a formula coefficient coefficients that you estimate, you can do your usual stuff,
Santiago: The squares and then you have these key here is these this fee function that does something that creates these curves right, and then you figure David with those,
Santiago: Naturally, the question is, are you think these curves now, what can we do with these curves and it turns out, you can do quite a bit actually,
Santiago: You can do descriptive stats Max Min media and variance confidence intervals, you can do interpolation,
Santiago: things such as connecting that that's right if you have meter reads and you want to show,
Santiago: A line, instead of using the default plotting method you can use functional analysis and connect the dots with a little bit a little bit more smoothly,
Santiago: You can do extrapolation of functional functional regression, if you want to some influential type work if you're doing some predictive work, you can use gams if you've ever used that you're using functional data analysis on the back end that uses cubic splines,
Santiago: Relatively newer approaches clustering you can cluster the curves and then, if you're doing a time series analysis, you can use some of these techniques as part of that as well,
Santiago: And here's the pitch right,
Santiago: I think it's worthwhile to explore functionally announces I know I found it useful and it's another tool in your toolbox, and then, if a question comes along from a stakeholder or,
Santiago: something you find something you have potentially a better fitting tool for the job, and if you've ever worked with your hands and you've ever built anything you know that the right tool make the jobs so much easier,
Santiago: As far as fitting the curve, as far as the method goes it's quite flexible,
Santiago: It allows you to fit occur below steffi function right that a non parametric function, a number of different ways for your bases are really good for where,
Santiago: Periodic data in this case meter reads tend to be periodic or semi periodic there's some kind of cyclicality two things so to it's good for that,
Santiago: He splines common mark cuban's find three words, etc, and then it's not only about fitting the curve it's benefiting the record right you want to make sure you,
Santiago: You fit,
Santiago: In the counterfeit residuals you're getting the right curve you're not overfitting you're not understanding there's a couple ways to fit the optimal Piromya squares,
Santiago: methodology, as well as a cannibalization technique and arguably the coolest thing about functional the analysis and the curves that you fit,
Santiago: Is that those curves are differential now At first I didn't realize how useful that can be,
Santiago: And I kind of glossed over it, and i've recently gone back and learn more and explore that area further because it opens up the treasure chest of information I think some areas have experience working with the image, for example, engineers my look at me to change,
Santiago: physicist use derivatives often right, but if you work I work, primarily in commercial functions marketing finance operations I haven't had a need to look at the rooms, but it really is interesting, and I have an example of that,
Santiago: In a bit, so we have our first stopping point I don't know 30 questions if not i'm just gonna go less water,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I can check over on slide out, but just to remind everyone if you want to ask questions either anonymously or with your name, and you can do so on slide oh and i'll put the link in the chat again, but the short link is RS td,io slash meetup bash questions,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): put them American,
Santiago: there's a question in the chat here about overfitting that's that's definitely possible if you were going to do any sort of,
Santiago: If you were just connecting the dots,
Santiago: And you probably wouldn't,
Santiago: Care too much about the fit if you're doing anything influential or you wanted,
Santiago: To take into account for own funding or underfitting I would suggest,
Santiago: doing a,
Santiago: split the beta your typical I for tuning try different number of bases functions see which one has,
Santiago: Some squares air you could also use the personalization technique that I found that to be probably the best approach,
Santiago: You can you can follow me, you can fit a fully parameters model,
Santiago: With a penalty your account for the overfitting are underfitting,
Santiago: I found it to be more powerful and,
Santiago: I don't want to get too into the weeds but hopefully that answers your question ensure, in summary, there are ways,
Santiago: to account in the dress,
underfitting,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): evening Santiago and feel free to unmute yourself if you want to add context to questions to or raise your hand and zoom and I can call on you,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): It should let you unmute yourself, there was an anonymous question that was what is the sample size, you need to fit the curves,
Good question,
Santiago: let's see I am working on stuff on the side so everything i'm sure i'll share after this section are snippets of applications that i'm working on as proof of concepts I work,
Santiago: And i've worked with millions of records, because you figured time series data gets so big so fast,
Santiago: Or you can work just 24 points right if I if i'm working with summarize meter reads let's say I have,
Santiago: So many questions that it's a perfect segue into the next section let's say I have a year's worth of meter reads I summarize them,
Santiago: By day right, so I mean by our 24 hours and i'll end up with 24 points right that's like the slide the picture we saw earlier with those red dots are 24 red dots one for each of the day, each of the hours that's all that's all you need to fit the curve,
Santiago: If you wanted to do a little bit more than some influential words like build confidence intervals, then just having those 24 summarize points won't do you any good, because you have no way of construct,
Santiago: A standard deviation you don't have that similar matrix so you can work with,
Santiago: you'll see this in a second, you can work with the summarize information in just 24 points in this example, or you can work with all the data and then you have,
Santiago: Access to more information, you can do a little bit more, but depending on your machine depending on your hardware it gets pretty out of control quickly,
Santiago: i'll show you in a second i'll try to remember to bring that up,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And I noticed, all you mentioned that's a good segue into the next one, so you can save some of the questions for the next pause to,
Santiago: yeah that's it, yes, thank you, if if you see something in,
Santiago: The in this section,
Santiago: A sparks and a further conversation on our previous question, or any other question from chat will address it,
Santiago: And now it makes a good point if you are doing a machine learning everything you do want to separate your testing train that's feel like that's that's a whole topic of its own, so I will go there, but yes,
Santiago: Okay, so we talked we talked about summarizing the time series data and in in the utility space, I found that this is probably the most common way to do that it's called the daily low profile,
Santiago: It is a way to summarize the consumption information to easily see trends right and there's different ways to do this load has definitions and consumption demand,
Santiago: The approach here is functional data analysis techniques it works for however you choose to summarize the data,
Santiago: i'm in marketing, so I you I tend to use the meme or like some tragedy tape measure me media to summarize, you can do the Max if you're more focused on,
Santiago: The grid and electrical generation capacity what's the maximum load that the system can handle or you can do an average, our goal is to find meaning,
Santiago: And once you have these little profiles, you can connect the dots I can talk about functional analysis that was one of the questions, how many how many points do you need,
Santiago: as little as whatever you have 24 in this case, or as many as you have you can build confidence intervals,
Santiago: And I find that useful, instead of just providing a point estimate going to provide a little bit more clarity as to what's the variants look like and then,
Santiago: The daily load profile is the most classic decomposition here, but there are others, you can decompose it any other way, and if you if you're a little familiar with time series you'll know,
Santiago: you'll know what kind of what that means I want to don't get into that too much here, but essentially what you're doing is decomposing a time series and summarizing it in some way,
Santiago: This is our first example, this is time to use information, this is an actual customers meter reads,
Santiago: This is only two weeks i'm working with about two years worth of data on the back end that would look very messy part of the whole thing, but this is essentially,
Santiago: The underlying data structure it's a time series, you can see there's like a family upward trending or anything but there are some cyclicality to the ups and downs, so if you study time series, you can look this and you can extract information from it,
Santiago: it's useful to summarize and decompose this information and that's where this daily live profile little profiles in general come in,
Santiago: that's step one we're going to decompose that time series,
Santiago: And what you're looking at here is two years worth of meetings,
Santiago: On the X axis, you have your day 24 hours in the day and your measure of consumption on the y axis each dot represents a,
Santiago: me to read for a particular day and out right, so you have about 700 days plotted here,
Santiago: Okay step one step two we're going to apply functional analysis and I don't show how to do that or anything,
Santiago: Just to showcase what you can do with it, and this always makes me trouble because it looks like static on screen kind of artsy if you've ever seen those those means are about deep learning art and when I will take on the back of the coyotes because it's funny,
Santiago: So what we've done is we fit functional curve to every day right so for the last two years, worth of meter reads we fit a curve to every one of those days and,
Santiago: You can you can see a couple things from your own you know don't get too into that but,
Santiago: It looks like at the bottom portion of consumption, so from between zero and 400 is where the majority of the consumption for this particular customer in the last few years it's there's some there's some outliers I guess i'll beyond that 400 range,
Santiago: Step three is summarized right, because this is useful in to do a couple of things like we talked about,
Santiago: You can summarize these curves we can summarize all these curves into a single curve, we can build confidence intervals, I would never present this to a stakeholder look at you like you're crazy,
Santiago: But this is much more readable right so we've summarized all those curves to produce a point as to the curve, maybe fit the 50s 24 dots,
Santiago: Your needs we extracted the standard deviation and variance component, because we had all those curves were able to build confidence intervals around that,
Santiago: and allows us to answer questions, depending on what that might be, but you can say something like on average you're 95% confident that consumption at this point in time is between a beef right a little bit more of a complete picture,
Santiago: And that's the daily low profile right, but there are other ways to decompose a time series, you can do day a week a month once a year in creative there might be seasonal components,
Santiago: Other than that, one to 24 hour period and the those three steps are the same across any of these decomposition you combos chooser decomposition you fit functional day analysis and then you summarize,
Santiago: and
Santiago: This is, in part, hosted by our CEO so as I was putting this together, I thought, one thing you can do was,
Santiago: decompose the time series in a couple of different ways collect those D compositions put them together in some in a shiny happy dashboard,
Santiago: And you will very quickly have a rough idea as to what the average behavior for our customers, for example, the frown on the top left,
Santiago: I probably want to use a line for this, but you could,
Santiago: Maybe bar chart would be more appropriate, but you see that, for this customer it's a business customer and you see that consumption is highs we Monday and Friday and there's an interaction effect weekends,
Santiago: Right consumption drops with the weekends on bond right you see the month and consumption tends to be higher on average in the winter months versus summer,
Santiago: Just kind of useful to see experimenting with different things playing around it's a very flexible technique,
Santiago: Okay second pause,
Santiago: There any,
questions,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Yes, there's a few other questions coming in, on slide Oh, but just want to let everyone know again to if you want to raise your hand on zoom or jump in live feel free to do so as well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But the other questions for someone was often with meter readings, you can have a lot of noise, do you need to clean the data and advance to remove outliers and other noise in your data,
Santiago: question,
Santiago: We have a whole,
Santiago: So in two parts, the first part, the raw materials are,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): cleaned up,
Santiago: From a production system by our engineers,
Santiago: So i'm extracting this from an already clean state in a database and where,
Santiago: I I don't do too much outside of that whatever they've done I don't do too much I just take it all in because i'm summarizing that information if there are outliers the kind of,
Santiago: taking care of my averaging right if you're afraid of if you if you're afraid that there are too many outliers instead of summarizing by the mean you can do the median,
Santiago: Or you can do a pre processing steps to say you want to use,
Santiago: there's so many different ways that,
Santiago: define an outlier however you choose, you can pre process and eliminate those data points and then just work with what remains,
Santiago: But I didn't do any of that here, and you know the whole two years,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): yeah there's there's one other question was can the FDA approach be used to estimate deviations from the norm like theft of electricity,
Santiago: I would imagine,
Santiago: it's a pretty robust technique I haven't done any sort of anomaly detection,
Santiago: But I would imagine you could,
Santiago: For example, if you had an estimate of words normal consumption is and then all of a sudden there's a spike you would see that right, if you if you build a,
Santiago: Confidence interval around what you thought to be true consumption true behavior build your confidence intervals to your account super wide 9% right, then something did come in that was way outside of that band that might be causing to read to flag it and best thing to further,
Santiago: But I haven't been too much of it,
Santiago: Now there you go Kelly thinking physio,
Santiago: So a lot, a lot of the,
Santiago: A lot of the techniques,
Santiago: you're used to principal component analysis clustering now they have functional counterparts,
Santiago: Let me be worth exploring,
Santiago: Doing,
Santiago: deliverance I found this to be really interesting,
Santiago: I outside of calculus didn't think I would use derivatives at work, it turns out to be really useful and one of the things i'm working on now is sort of a feature engineering techniques to build the features for machine learning predictive type work,
Santiago: i'll show you a little bit about what what I mean by that,
Santiago: In itself, just opened up a new realm of analysis for me die been fascinated by,
Santiago: And we're going to revisit this we fit this this curve this customer,
Santiago: And now we're going to differentiate this curve and we're going to look at the velocity and acceleration of this particular customer, so this average average behavior occur,
Santiago: And there's a couple interesting things here, if you look at the Max velocity in the minimum right these global global extreme,
Santiago: If you're almost able to describe some of the behavior of the customer right, so you can say something like perhaps on peak hours for this particular customer in between 8am and five you now, knowing that this is a business customer you're like yeah that makes sense,
Santiago: And if you want to do for fun if you're doing calculus you can do the second derivative test right where the first derivative is zero look at the second derivative is greater than zero or less than zero that tells you something about whether that,
Santiago: That time is an extra minute one,
Santiago: apple,
Santiago: Next, this is a classic this was new to me, this is a classic way of looking at derivative information in engineering and physics,
Santiago: In it it's the same information we just looked at, but slightly presented in a different manner it's really good for cyclical type of data,
Santiago: In this case it works really nicely consumption and meter reading type data and what you see, is what we said earlier,
Santiago: All the way to the right and the positive and the X axis you ever lost 78 that's 8am is Max velocity if we work all the way to the left, we see five,
Santiago: Minimum velocity and then you see these cycles almost in circles right, you have this big circle, to the rain positive velocity section,
Santiago: You have a small circle centered around zero maybe like a plateau in consumption and then you have two periods of ramping down and consumption one better than the other,
Santiago: And that's essentially what's happening here right between the hours of four and 10am the consumption for this particular customer on average starts to ramp up and peaks at 8am and then between,
Santiago: Somewhere in the mid day plateaus, then you have two periods of ramping down the primary ramping down period in between, about two to 8pm 678 pm, then you have,
Santiago: This final ramping down for the day comes, like they're closing up shop for the end of the day,
Santiago: that's pretty interesting I I personally never looked at it this way, I find it really interesting to describe behavior customer behavior in this way and it's another descriptive feature to add information and context to any analysis you're doing,
Santiago: And we can translate translate this back to the original the original data right,
Santiago: We have those four periods that first period of the day is ramping up you have this plateau in consumption that primary ramp down,
Santiago: And then you have that closing up shop period, and then the cycle repeats ramp up, but a ramp down ramped up but I thought was really fascinating I thought was really cool,
Santiago: One of the things I am working on on this as a proof of concept work is to extract moves,
Santiago: Global extreme,
Santiago: Using the first riveted as individual on peak periods, for example, right now, I consumers energy let's say we have a predefined window for what we call on peak hours for residential customers,
Santiago: I don't remember how we can move with those but let's say from A to B,
Santiago: Well it's very broad and we ask customers to fit into that mold but using something like derivatives, you can you can define what on peak hours are for each customer, so you can be hyper personalized be much more customer centric,
Santiago: So i'm building something our building the data separate customers to define those on personal on peak hours to potentially use an explorer in as features in other type of works,
Santiago: i'll stop there,
Santiago: Any questions any thoughts,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I don't see other questions specific to the top Oh, I see,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): reggie you just asked a question and slider would you want to jump in and ask it live,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I can't oh don't have a MIC i'll ask a question, but it is, what are the approaches to account for he gosh Am I gonna say this word heterogeneity other than fitting separate models to investigate interactions with some X variable like location,
Santiago: Good question I don't I haven't done too much of that my,
Santiago: There is functional regression, which will that will help you with that,
Santiago: If I understand what you're saying correctly, if you had other components and you want to do some sort of functional,
Santiago: analysis with you could use functional regression it's very similar to what you're used to just,
Santiago: And a layer of abstraction with functions or curves as opposed to individual features Kelly again when Thank you I haven't used a PC mo I know it does does on the back end not too much man um what else,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So I see quran current tema apologize if I mispronounce your name, you have your hand raised, you want to jump in,
Korantema Owusu Darko: hi I really liked the idea, can you hear me,
Korantema Owusu Darko: Yes, yes, I really like the idea about using the derivatives to find the peak periods, so I was thinking of if I have,
Korantema Owusu Darko: meter read from let's say 100 customers and then I wanted to find which customers have the same peak periods,
Korantema Owusu Darko: So I could see relatively how I could do it for one and then do it for all of them, but how my general ideas i'm thinking, I can write a code which would give me okay these customers are always,
Korantema Owusu Darko: These are the serial numbers, the meters of customers who have teachers between eight and five these customers, which are the period between six and 10 I don't know this that's what I was thinking is that something where you think this can be applied,
Santiago: that's a good question it's very,
Santiago: prescient that's actually exactly what i'm working on right now is once you've defined it's almost two steps right once you've defined these on peak periods for all customers,
Santiago: You can,
Santiago: You can aggregate that information to construct group level,
Santiago: Empty periods right so let's say I have your example 100 meter reads i've defined with the anti periods are using derivatives, then you can do one of two things really for your purpose, you probably just cluster,
Santiago: You can just cluster the information and see which customers have similar on peak periods,
Santiago: Where else can you do that's probably that's probably how I would approach that problem and then i'm working on a,
Santiago: Internal White Paper that does that very thing actually it's a,
Santiago: it's a clusters,
Santiago: About like 60,000 customers worth of information and defines on peak periods for each cluster,
Santiago: they're answering the question is that what you're thinking,
Korantema Owusu Darko: Yes, yes, because i'm the type of data I work with is renewable energy, so we wanted to know which people are using so,
Korantema Owusu Darko: will be best fit for solar energy, because they are empty period is in the daytime which people be best for our energy goes down period is in different yeah so that's where I was heading,
Santiago: yeah that's,
Excellent,
Santiago: Questions have been great that's a perfect segue into the next section there's been some recent research,
Santiago: About clustering these curves so you could for example fit a curve to all your hundred customers and then cluster the curves themselves as opposed to treating the,
Santiago: Time series measurements let's say you had 24 hours, instead of treating 24 hours as individual features that are highly correlated you can cluster the curves,
Santiago: And funny enough that is next section,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I had almost like a timed it out perfectly,
Santiago: yeah it's it's almost as i've been learning, this is this this technique and applying this the fitting of the curves,
Santiago: connecting the dots derivatives and then clustering has been my progression through this learning process,
Santiago: The first thing was just getting comfortable and fitting the Kurds trying different ways to fit the curves for your for your bases Q explains wavelength, you name it and then getting the dirt information how's that useful building use cases,
Santiago: showing the utility and then the question came up just like yours well what else can we do with that and just just occurred to me while,
Santiago: i'm in marketing a lot of what we do segmentation clustering want to be more targeted or messaging and all that well, can we cluster these this information we cluster this stuff and it turns out, you can,
Santiago: And for this i'm using the Hello world example,
Santiago: of functional data analysis,
Santiago: There is a package and Article FDA in it there's this data, if you want to get in and play with it it's from it's Canadian it's average Canadian weather temperature,
Santiago: For I think 36 or 60 some number of Canadian stations some weather stations in Canada,
Santiago: For a year or so they've averaged this kind of it looks almost like a low profile instead of be ours you're looking at days in the year and an average the temperatures, that the red line there's the average of the group,
Santiago: And, before I proceed take a look at this and ask yourself if you had to kranz or coloring pencils pencils whatever and I asked you to color in the lines based on how you would group these things into two different groups, I would you do it right, keeping in mind,
Santiago: How we've done it traditionally at work has been to treat the features in this case hours of the early days of the year, in my case it's been hours in the day,
Santiago: 24 in this example one through 365 treat those features as features and a clustering and a traditional pursuing process,
Santiago: The features are highly correlated right there depending on each other, so you need some kind of dimension reduction technique principal component analysis, for example,
Santiago: In this case I extracted two PCs that was like 95% variance, and this is what comes up and it looks it looks like it makes sense right so there's not really any questions, it looks,
Santiago: Pretty straightforward and this is your traditional clustering PCA dimension reduction, if needed, and you do need it and then canes you can probably do hierarchical clustering as well and extract to,
Santiago: Tony just means,
Santiago: And then,
Santiago: This is relatively newer,
Santiago: This is clustering occurs themselves via something it's a library in our code of fun ht DC,
Santiago: I think the first Paper describing this keynote 2017 2015 maybe mature but it's recent, and it does something very similar,
Santiago: And what enough from a functional perspective and it looks very different from the clustering outcome looks very different from the traditional lettering measure, this is, this is why early on, I said it's a another tool in your toolbox,
Santiago: Different results in the depends on your use case, maybe this better aligns with your what your needs are,
Santiago: To me, when I looked at that black and white curve, the black and white lines and originally this aligns more with what I thought funny enough, but then i've asked others in preparation for the presentation and they said the traditional lined up with what they thought was kind of interesting,
Santiago: That is it for that section I don't haven't explored this too in depth, I do have another project i'm working on the colleague to build this out more detail,
Santiago: and comparing the different approaches to see if this curve clustering idea is something that we want to adopt in place or have, in addition to our traditional clustering processes,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So I know on the topic of packages, as you just mentioned FDA someone else had asked are there other packages that you could recommend to us for functional data analysis,
Santiago: yeah absolutely,
Santiago: FDA is classic Matthew mentions the refund the package that's really good,
Santiago: there's a supplemental package to FDA FDA,
Santiago: usc I think it, it gives you a little bit more functionality, for example in FDA you can average the curves through mean,
Santiago: With this supplemental package you can do the median and bunch of other stuff,
Santiago: there's a couple clustering actually if you wait a second,
Santiago: Every sources, I would recommend to visit the archives fantastic view this is really neat they have a running list of all available functional data analysis libraries in our and,
Santiago: that's how I discovered the clustering portion there's a small snippet there that describes the different techniques for curve clustering,
Santiago: See,
Santiago: I would say just visit that explorer,
Santiago: I got started on this journey,
Santiago: In school actually we were learning about splines and gams generalized headed models and I was really interested with the idea and I asked my professors, where I can get more information,
Santiago: About functional data analysis and my Professor pointed me towards worked worked by Professor ramsey,
Santiago: So I purchased these two books here functional data analysis its theoretical it's the math behind things it's really good for understanding what the heck's going on in the background,
Santiago: For an upline perspective functional data analysis with our in matlab is a great resource actually right here,
Santiago: was doing something this morning with it and I were friends that all the time,
Santiago: they're also really great,
Santiago: Public posts Joseph I believe in RStudio employee, he has three or four posts on our views that are really good,
Santiago: there's an online course that's in depth and quite lengthy and i'm sure that would cover your questions there's if you're interested in games specifically there's a great course by one Ross on that information,
Santiago: There are other books too they're really good that I haven't purchased level we're stuck with these two and then the are In summary, the our ecosystem for functional analysis is really rich, if you want to do something it's there,
Santiago: And then I do know, there are a few resources in Python as well,
Santiago: And that is it that's all I had,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you so much Santiago I that was awesome I see there's a lot of other great questions here too,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But on that topic of all those great resources, I did just want to say to everyone, as well, if you have other things to share to feel free to put them into the chat as well or other things that have been helpful for you and learning FDA,
Santiago: there's a there's a Joseph one of joseph's posts on our new our new blog shows a,
Santiago: It looks like,
Santiago: Children have drawn a blank on the name but it's a map of,
Santiago: How the different packages will lead to each other in at the Center is the refund package that's getting a one on one chat,
Santiago: chat section, but also FDA the FDA package and the refund package are pretty much the source of all newer works it's really cool I would say check that out that's really neat image,
Santiago: yeah there's a lot of courses and so rich explore if you're interested,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Let me go over to some of the slide oh questions and as a reminder, you can always raise your hand on zoom to if you want to ask live,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): let's see,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Your question was on the weather time series analysis,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): let's see the weather time series analysis based on what criteria will be give color i'm not understanding the question exactly,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So feel feel free to weigh in,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): If you want to add any other context to that question to or Santiago if you understand what they might be asking there,
Santiago: I think I get it in the traditional clustering paradigm, you can since our features are so really dealing with clarity dimension reduction is almost,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): A necessity right,
Santiago: So using PCA on the features treating them like independent features and extracting some PCs is the way and that's,
Santiago: I would say, I think that answers that question from a traditional perspective,
Santiago: From a curve clustering perspective it's doing pretty much the same thing it's doing like you see Chad, probably a functional PCA it's doing that, on the background in the back end to,
Santiago: And extracting some kind of variance and extracting the PCs basis variance metric maybe I honestly haven't explored the inner workings too much, I find it useful to focus on applications first and if it's I can do, I can do it, first of all, and then,
Santiago: And then I can meets my needs, then I go back and I start reading a little bit more about information, the details,
Santiago: For example, i've read the research paper a little bit to understand what's going on what's the background and it's pretty it's pretty understandable if you have some understanding the concepts such so academic that it's beyond reach,
Santiago: For example, the F been ht DC has a has a their papers it's pretty approachable i'm saying check it out, have a good understanding that's what it's doing but it's it's like the functional counterpart, the traditional classroom it's doing very similar things,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you, I see someone else said I know the gans course or GA and what is the difference between cans and FDA are they the same thing,
Santiago: sort of,
Santiago: deal yeah yes, I guess, in short, yes,
Santiago: James us to explain, so that, if you remember that early math formula that linear combination, if you think of like the regression component, you can intercept and then you have beta coefficient of times some beta coefficient that fee function builds out,
Santiago: The vehicle for the non parametric boundary then on pyramid function, there are different ways to fit that in games I don't know if you can switch that i've only ever seen it with Cuba explains,
Santiago: In which case, that is FDA that is functional data analysis,
Santiago: let's see you can generalize further and do maybe,
Like,
Santiago: functional regression on your own using the functional the analysis techniques,
Santiago: And then define a feature function as whatever you want it, for your for your series wavelengths monotone automobile whatever I think games specifically cute ones,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you, Thomas, I saw you had your hand raised earlier on, if you want to jump in with your question,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And maybe it was answered from slido but feel free to jump in again that Kelly, I see just ask a question, the chat to if you want to ask live,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Oh, I can always ask the questions for people to feel free to put a little like I should have said that sorry a star next to your question, if you ask in the zoom chat to and want me to ask it, the question was curious to know if anyone also tried using wavelength for curve modeling,
Santiago: I haven't yet,
Santiago: In one of the textbooks by Professor ramsey key touts it as,
Santiago: A supposed to be pretty good I haven't really worked with it too much i've mostly stuck with the four year series, for your bases expansion and Q explains,
Santiago: For me,
Santiago: For me to read, I found before your series a 14 bases functions work really well,
Santiago: In except in rare cases where,
Santiago: I have seen this in seen this in business customers more aware,
Santiago: Consumption can be,
Santiago: about the for your series works really well for periodic basis right it's built by science and co signs and but it doesn't do very well when things are somethings jack it doesn't jump up and what doesn't adjust up to use,
Santiago: The term friendly,
Santiago: If your consumption was like bit strange, but from nothing straight up back down these very jaggy rises and piece, for us to use one approximate that very well, she was wines with it, that much better,
Santiago: There are downsides to that too right,
Santiago: he's at the comfort differential different route that differential ability if that's what you're interested in or,
Santiago: The endpoints keep in mind, since we kind of wonky so if you're trying to produce something there that might get weird,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Well, thank you so much, I think, oh, there was a question earlier,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): from someone that was more related to your coding question anonymous question was they need to know how to change the data class for all variables from double to original class without doing it manually when they import a csv file and a few people were helping in the chat as well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But their question further question was they want to change everything for like 50 variables at once, and how to do that,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I know it's hard to kind of ask coding questions here is it does,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): That make sense okay,
Santiago: yeah that's actually pretty easy and, all things to reverse,
Santiago: So shout out RStudio,
Santiago: Using stuff like that across function deeply are across you select your fields, for example, you were interested in,
Santiago: All fields and be super easy if you needed a certain number of fields, need to be something like people are across columns select where contains, for example, if you have a set prefix or suffix or something and then function would be whatever you need to justify,
Santiago: I saw as part of this since i'm using actual customer information, I have to add noise to me compliance standards and all that stuff and I take I do that very thing I take a read in the day, the raw data, and then I do you think tigers I do in the prosecution apply noise,
Santiago: And then I just takes care of everything on American there's probably other ways to do it, but it has to be a problem, I know it's easy,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you, and I just want to make sure that answered whoever's question that was feel free to respond back anonymously inside out to and if not, you can always ask me one on one as well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And then another question was how often do you need to reset the curves or clustering,
Santiago: Almost over to generalize a little further if you were,
Santiago: Depending on what you were doing if you're doing a one off analysis,
Santiago: Then only once right if you were putting this into production to do something,
Santiago: Like predicting something or clustering mutual customers, then,
Santiago: you're entering a broader conversation about when do you read two models in general right, so if you're doing something production, you should have some sort of like data drift type pipelines that assess as your data changed it was a previous comment about outliers if if,
Santiago: If your input data has tended to be one way and all of a sudden just behavior changes and say, do the coconut or some something else,
Santiago: Then it's probably time for me to write and you should have a flag that says hey just a heads up or even break your procedure and say your input data is way different than what it used to be,
Santiago: it's kind of a broader topic,
Santiago: there's no I don't think there's a set defined period,
Santiago: But there's a lot of research out there and help guide that conversation as to when I will often,
Santiago: And it probably depends on the nature of your data to if you're doing something at the elite level from a frequent if you're working on aggregate aggregated yearly meter reads then once or twice, once or twice a year we're probably suffice,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): awesome Thank you Karen time I see you have your hand raised to if you want to jump in,
Korantema Owusu Darko: hi,
Korantema Owusu Darko: Yes, I was still thinking about the clustering and I was thinking about what she says is,
Korantema Owusu Darko: There sort of bias in the data in terms of for my hundred customers, I do not have data, the same amount of data first one customer I only have data for one month,
Korantema Owusu Darko: And then maybe a couple of days in one month and for some customers, I have every day for six months, and like for that duration would that affect in the chemistry,
It shouldn't,
Santiago: The functional data analysis techniques are really robust,
Santiago: From in my cases in some sense i've typically work with,
Santiago: Like i'll prep the data right, I will look at only customers who have had at least six months of a meter reads,
Santiago: All eliminate anywhere where consumption is zero, but some people just activate a meter never use it right get rid of those people so for prep i've used,
Santiago: To be called equally spaced basic functions with the,
Santiago: The the called nuts,
Santiago: Number of knots,
Santiago: can equally space in my case, for example in this in the presentation today there 24 right because i'm working 24 hours in the day I define and that each hour of the day, but let's say in your case you had,
Santiago: One one month 215 months seven months 12 and you want to use equally spaced not because you don't have them what you might do is fit curves individually to each customer,
Santiago: using whatever data, you do have whatever whatever periods, you have right or not, so you have to find those for each each customer and then work with those,
Santiago: respective curves,
Santiago: For, for example, with my work, since I don't have that issue, I can work with all the customers at once,
Santiago: And that,
Santiago: clustering know in the actually get in a White Paper, I was talking about i'm working with about 60,000 customers so it's a matrix of by 60 60,000 and by,
Santiago: Not filming it's 24 and by 60,000 feet right, so my customers are feature is really why I can just treat them all at once, because the data is the same,
Santiago: As we have some data for all 24 hours and makes it really easy in your case, the only thing I really switches is you might have to fit the purpose of each individual customer and then work with that they output, like those those those groups, as opposed to where you put them all at once,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you, let me just check to see the other,
Korantema Owusu Darko: Questions I know a few people,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): have to drop right at the top of the hour, so just did just want to let you know I shared a few links in the chat to everyone and provide feedback for the meetups,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): If you are interested in speaking at a future meetup whether that's energy or another industry that you work in and then also a calendar of upcoming events to,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): One last question that was on the slide oh Santiago was someone asked if you would be able to share this code for them to try it or, if you have that shared on github somewhere,
Santiago: I don't,
Santiago: Only because it's it's customer information I don't have to meet compliance needs and standards and go through a whole,
Santiago: process, so I don't know if I can share I can certainly share the presentation, but I don't know if I can share any code,
Santiago: I might be able to create a markdown type file and just hide that chunk So you see anything there, but still show the steps after the fact, I might be able to do that, but I don't know,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Okay, thank you, I can follow up in the after and,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): i'll share all the resources and slides with the,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Recording,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): as well, so that will go up to our CD YouTube and i'll put that playlist here for all the meetups in the chat too,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So i'll work on hopefully sharing that by the end of the day tomorrow to,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Do one last check for for any questions feel free to unmute yourself and jump in,
and
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Try to count at least seven seconds here Thank you so much Santiago for an awesome presentation and and sharing all those resources with us too,
yeah,
Santiago: Thank you, everybody,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you, if anybody wants to stay on and chat feel free to to stay,